and we gotta know where the freaking
dark matter plan is I've never heard of
this that's amazing okay it's a
hypothetical it's a hypothetical but
dark matter doesn't like to Clump you
know it's it's very diffuse it interacts
very weakly and so it's kind of hard to
um collapse it down when normal gas gets
hot it cools down it radiates and so it
cools down the Gas collapses and
eventually it cools down to a point
where you can actually start to form
stars because the gases has concentrated
so much dark matter doesn't really do
that but there are some varieties of
Dark Matter models that allow for a bit
more clumpiness it's allowed to kind of
interact a bit more strongly it's a
fairly extreme idea but in some extreme
versions it could potentially form a
dark matter Planet but it would be
larger than the sun uh it would end of
order of you know just a few Earth
masses and it would be very weakly bound
together but then what right would you
have to call it a planet I I really
don't care about it it's a gathering
yeah over here